warner brothers released the first
teaser trailer for the batman
which sees robert pattinson taking up
the role of the caped crusader
while a lot of the plot is still unknown
the trailer gives us a number of hints
about what pattinson's batman will look
like
who he'll be facing off against and of
course
plenty of easter eggs here is everything
you might have missed
[Music]
the first shot of the trailer shows a
man in disguise
duct taping another man's face with the
words no
more lies written across the tape this
man
is likely the riddler played by actor
paul dano
you'll notice he's wearing a mask with
glasses on top of it
fans have pointed out the resemblance to
the infamous zodiac killer
who went on a murder spree in the 1960s
and 70s
this look is quite a departure from the
villain's famous bright green outfits in
past batman films and tv shows
we then hear and see actor jeffrey
wright
from your secret friend who's stepping
into the shoes of
jim gordon who was portrayed by actors
pat
hingle gary oldman and jk simmons in
previous films
gordon picks up an envelope addressed to
the batman
that seems to be from the riddler the
card inside has an
owl on it which could be a reference to
the court of owls
a secret organized crime society made up
of a league of assassins called talents
the left half shows a riddle what does a
liar do
when he's dead at the bottom there's
also a handwritten code
the zodiac killer was also known for
leaving
similar-looking coded messages the
riddle in this card is not deciphered in
the trailer
but game designer mike selinker and
twitter user andrew lane
both think they've cracked it with the
solution
he lies still in another shot
we see the word lies scrawled in red
over a series of newspapers that
repeatedly mention a man named don
zoom in under the headline don's done it
again
and it reads mayor mitchell jr wins
historic third term
so don mitchell jr is mayor of gotham in
the batman
and possibly the corpse as well another
newspaper reads
moroni drug bust in the batman universe
salvatore moroney is an infamous mobster
best known for creating two-face after
splashing acid on his face
while he is not seen in the trailer john
tutturo will play mob boss carmine
falcone
so the mob will somehow play a role here
a background voice says you're becoming
quite a celebrity
that's the voice of actor andy circus
who plays bruce wayne's butler alfred
the line
also suggests that it's still early in
batman's career
director matt reeves revealed during the
dc
fandom event that the film is not an
origin story and bruce is actually on
year two
of his crime fighting career reeves
cited several films from the 1970s as
inspiration
like taxi driver the french connection
and chinatown
taxi driver focuses on a character
crusading against a crime-ridden city
the latter two center on detectives as
well as drug smuggling
and elite corruption which seem to be
the focus of the batman as well
another shot shows a car with doa
or dead on arrival written on the side
driving into a funeral
based on this portrait it might be mayor
mitchell's funeral the man who gets out
of the car
has an envelope addressed to the batman
duct taped to his chest
that looks similar to the one seen
earlier in the trailer
a few classic batman characters are
introduced
in the trailer blank and you might miss
catwoman
portrayed here by zoe kravitz
and the man you see in these shots here
is oswald cobblepot
aka the penguin he doesn't look or
dress much like the penguin played by
danny devito in 1992's batman returns
according to reeves like batman
cobblepot is still early in his career
and not quite the infamous criminal
audiences know
and who is the actor playing the penguin
that is actually colin farrell who is
rendered
unrecognizable thanks to convincing
prosthetic makeup
just like with the penguin you will
notice some differences between this
batman
and previous batman iterations reeves
wanted to give the suit a more handmade
feel
that hadn't quite reached the levels of
ones worn by the likes of michael keaton
and christian bale
and then there's another notable aspect
of batman we see
in the batman that has rarely been seen
before
black makeup under his eyes when he
takes off his cowl
wayne would need to wear under eye
makeup so nobody can spot his real skin
past batman's have done the same but
whenever they have taken
their cowls off the makeup isn't there
during the same moment when batman takes
his helmet off
you can hear a voice say
and bruce wayne replies
as the trailer focuses on gotham's
corruption
could wayne be finding out that he's
closer to the city's criminal underworld
than he thinks
well in the video game batman the
telltale
series wayne's father thomas wayne
actually has ties to falcone
and for one final reference to the
riddler
the character's signature question marks
pop up
when showing the movie's release date
did we miss any details from the batman
trailer
let us know in the comments
i'm vengeance